our next presenter can currently be seen
on the los angeles stage playing Norma
Desmond a woman who had very little
interest in sound effects editing don't
tell me have to explain this come on I'm
referring of course to the silence Green
heroine of the new musical version of
the oscar-winning film Sunset Boulevard
its star herself has been nominated for
five Oscars so I guess she's ready for
that close-up now ladies and gentlemen
Miss Glenn Close
she has made 44 movies light romances
and Dark One's epic adventures and
costume dramas comedies and even one of
our most beloved musicals
she played nuns and nannies nice ladies
and occasionally ladies who weren't so
very nice but always a lady if there was
a main line to her career it was as a
surrogate mom to troubled teenagers to
haunted children and most often to men
who would somehow forgotten to grow up
until they met her that is in her
singular way she combines warmth with
elegance passion with patience common
sense with uncommon wit great strength
with even greater vulnerability for
three decades she has been a radiant
presence on our screens this year the
Academy's Board of Governors has awarded
an honorary Oscar to this lovely woman
whose name is Deborah Carr
ladies and gentlemen Miss Deborah Carr
thank you thank you there should be some
more words for thank you shouldn't there
I've never been so frightened in all my
life but I feel better now because I
know I'm among friends I feel honored to
be here tonight because in receiving
this award I have been asked to join so
many others whose achievements I have
long admired William Wyler Orson Welles
Gene Kelly Billy Wilder just to name a
few there are also those who helped pave
the long road I have traveled friends to
whom I am eternally grateful Cary Grant
Bob Mitchum Elia Kazan John Huston and
many more as well as all the men and
women behind the lights who helped me
during the many years in which I was
fortunate enough to work in this
industry you have all made my life truly
a happy one thank you from the bottom of
my heart